hey guys Eric back with another
fortnight new update vending machines
are now in the game and they're located
in different parts of the map they show
up in different types of rarities and
they will cost different sets of
materials the common one will be a
hundred materials the uncommon will be
200 the rare will be 300 the epic will
be 400 and the legendary will be 500 of
course again as mentioned it will be
random so depending on you know your
vending machine yet you might get
something really good or maybe something
not so great but this is a great way to
kind of spend some of those extra
materials you have so we're gonna go in
check out some of these spots I
personally haven't found one myself yet
so we're on the exploration together oh
here you go so here is a vending machine
and fortnight we are currently at retail
or next to retail row between salty and
retail that one cost 300 brick it looks
like it's cycles let's see do we want
another shotgun not really or is it
random no I think you can buy what you
want depending on one schools to find
out oh I don't have the kind all right
cool so I bought a pump and I could pry
by the hunting rifle I would assume oh I
know I can't because I don't have 300
brick but there you go so it looks like
it cycles through multiple guns at
different supply currencies and then you
buy said thing so that's pretty cool
we can try to find another one all right
let's take a look I supposed to be one
around here ish
up I hear it I hear you vending machine
so here you go it's another 300 it's
another rare I guess we just keep
finding rare ones we have enough to buy
something so what do we want oh we can
only buy the would one right now SMG
will buy the AR well we need it where
you can only buy that one anywhere
and what's last time
oh it's double SMG okay so it's it's
obviously like completely random oh
there it is
purple vending machine so confirm
there's one across the bridge you can
get a semi-auto sniper semi-auto sniper
or was our last one or the new
long-range shotgun I wish I had 400 uh
stone for that up there's someone
breaking down trees over there so yeah
here's that vending machine as mentioned
here's an epic one 400 material this is
one of those unlucky situations a double
semi-auto sniper but I guess if you only
had one currency that works out
obviously so yeah they're littered all
over the map so check those out at your
leisure
so anyways that was a quick look at the
vending machines obviously there's a
five tiers of rarity we found mainly
rare ones which is the blue one at the
end there we found one across the bridge
or near the bridge that was purple
they're gonna cost different things 100
for the common white vending machine 200
for the green uncommon a vending machine
300 for the rare blue of vending machine
400 for the epic purple vending machine
and 500 for the legendary gold mending
machine depending on the vending machine
obviously you might get three different
weapons you might get two of the same
and one different one we even saw a cozy
campfire so check out this map this is
kind of like a rough approximation of
different locations for the vending
machines that you can find them at
they're not always gonna be there but
you know fun little thing they added
here into the game so make sure to
follow gamespot of course as we continue
to cover the weekly battle past
challenges as well as some of these
other new updates locations and things
like that thank you so much and see you
guys next time
[Music]
you
[Music]